yes that's my honey things might not be
so sweet between Vanessa Hudgens and
Austin Butler anymore
the couple has called it quits after
more than eight years of dating fans
speculated that the pair was done after
it appeared that they didn't spend the
holidays together the 31 year old
actress posted photos of herself
unaccompanied on New Year's Eve and days
later the High School Musical star
shared photos from a winter vacay in
Switzerland photos that didn't include
Austin Vanessa who has been very open
about her feelings towards Austin I
think it's so important to have a person
who is you're up hasn't posted a photo
of the once upon a time in Hollywood
actor on Instagram since Halloween when
the two were dressed in Gothic costumes
with their dog Darla Austin hasn't
shared a pic of Vanessa on Instagram
since the movie premiere for his film
once upon a time in Hollywood in July
Grant said he doesn't post that often
his last post to date was October 10th
2019 in July the comeback to me singer
publicly praised her then boo when it
was announced he would portray Elvis
Presley in the upcoming Baz Luhrmann
directed biopic she wrote on Instagram
quote I am over the moon I can't wait so
proud of my honey
in fact Vanessa has always spoken highly
of Austin when et chatted with her in
2018 she gushed over him by running
through all of his accomplishments I am
so stoked for him right now I'm like the
fact that he just did Broadway for the
first time just did a film with Jim
Jarmusch and it's about to do a movie
with Quinton I'm like I can't
I'm so proud and we'll always have each
other's backs so it's nice earlier that
year Vanessa addressed speculation that
the two would get married admitting she
and Austin weren't filling the pressure
no because if I felt pressure under a
relationship we wouldn't been together
for almost seven years each couple has
their own journey
a journey that has come to an end
[Music]